Add traffic lights to the long and growing list of electronic devices...
...that have now been hacked.
A security expert in New York says that he was able to take control...
...of Manhattan's traffic light system and cause a traffic jam at will.
And that he was inspired from movies...
...because a cyber-terrorist in Die Hard, Die Hard 4: Live Free or Die,...
...took control remotely of the traffic system.
And so he started looking around to see if he could do it and he did.
He could also take control of the same system,...
...which is used in 40 different US cities and nine different countries.
The same system is used in Los Angeles, San Francisco, New York,...
...Washington, D.C. and other cities around the world.
And what makes it even more bizarre...
...is he said he was able to do it from a drone that he flew over the systems.